بينما يعتقد البعض ان المال هو سر السعاده
والنجاح فان عقود من البحث اثبتت ان امرا
اخر يقف وراء النجاح فاصفه واحده يشترك
فيها الاشخاص الناجحون دوما وهو ما يؤكد
ان هذه الصفه من عوامل النجاح الاساسيه
خاصه في مجال المال والاعمال والحياه
الوظيفيه هذه الصفه المشتركه بين الاشخاص
الناجحين هي الوعي الذاتي فبحسب خبيره في
علم النفس والفلسفه بجامعه الامريكيه من
شان هذه الصفه ان تؤدي الى تواصل اكثر
فاعليه واحده اقوى وزياده الابداع
والانتاجيه كما ان هذا النوع من فهم الناس
لمعتقداتهم وقدراتهم بشكل افضل يجعلهم
اكثر نجاحا وسعاده
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا من البحرين استشاريه تطوير
الموارد البشريه والتنميه الذاتيه عبير
الباتوغ عبير يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معنا في
صباح العربيه دراسه تقول ان الوعي الذاتي
صفه يشترك فيها الناجحون يعني لو تشرحينا
اكثر من الناحيه الوظيفيه
سهلا صباح الخير في البدايه صوتي واضح جدا
يا عبير اهلا بك
اهلا وسهلا حقيقه الوعي بالذات هو مش
الخصله اللي تضمنه النجاح هي هي اولى
الخصل التي تضمن للشخص اختيارات تتناسب
معه مع معتقداته ومفضلاته وقيمه لاعب
الذات ما يضمن النجاح بس يضمن لك الاختيار
الافضل بما يتناسب معه الوعي بالذات هي
احدى نقاط خلينا نقول الايموشنا
الذكاء العاطفي
الذكاء العاطفي يتكون من في مدارس تقول
اربع نقاط في مدرسه خمس نقاط او خمس محاور
اهمها الوعي بالذات وبعد الوعي بالذات
اداره الذات هو باقي النقاط لها علاقه
باداره الاخرين واداره العلاقات طيب انت
لما تكون ورعي بذاتك عبير انا صراحه خليني
احكي لك شغله بس انا صراحه لهلا مش فاهمه
بالضبط شو يعني الوعي الذاتي صراحه
شو يعني كل انسان عنده منظور مختلف للحياه
طب كيف بدي اعرف ان الوعي الذاتي الخاص بي
سليم مثلا
صحيح كل انسان عنده منظور مختلف للحياه بس
مش كل انسان واضح واضحه معه قيم الشخصيه
يعني انت لو بتعرفي شو قيمتك بتعرفي
تختاري بتعرفي شو اللي تقولين للنعم شنو
اللي تقولين لا وعلى اي اساس انت قاعده
تفعلين اي قيمه من قيم الحياه عندك لما ما
يكون في وعي واضح بقيمك الخاصه يعني انت
في البيت الواحد بدو تشتركون في مبادئكم
واخلاقياتكم بس لا تشتركون في قيامكم
الشخصيه عشان كده اختياراتكم مختلفه
في الوظيفه اكثر يجعل الانسان اكثر ابداعا
واكثر انتاجيه واكثر تفوقا لو يطبق في
الوظيفه
بالتاكيد لانه الوعي الذاتي يستمر يعني
اكثر من هي اكثر من اختيارات هي حتى على
اساليب تعامل يعني ممكن انا ما اكون واعيه
بذاتي ان انا احب اتعامل معه
اتعامل مع بشر اروح اختار وظيفه الطلب اني
اكون اتعامل مع بشر من وين راح ابداع
طبيعتي ما ما تساعدني ان انا اسوي هاي
الشيك احنا اليوم عندنا اختبارات نسويها
على اساس نساعد الانسان انه هو يوعب ذاته
يعني بما ان كلنا جاي ليخدم رساله معينه
طبيعيا اللي ممكن يكون طبيب مش نفسه اللي
ممكن يبيع عبير
اذا كان الانسان غير منسجم في عمله هل
الازمه داخليه بوعيه الذاتي كيف يفكر
وينظر الى الامور ام بفعل العوامل
الخارجيه
تكون داخليه وقد تكون خارجيه يعتمد يعني
لو هو واعي واعي بالامور اللي تناسبه
ومختار مكان لا يتناسب معه اذا العمليه
داخليه الافضل انه يختار مكان اخر قد يكون
مختار مكان يتناسب معه لكن الديناميكيات
العلاقات في المكان غير صحيه فهو هنا يقع
في مشكله
فتعتمد على الوضع
واحنا كمان بنشكرك جزيل الشكر عبير ومنشير
كمان بعد ما نختم مع عبير المعتوق في فئه
موارد البشريه والتنميه الذاتيه شكرا
جزيلا لك